لم يرغب الرئيس الفرنسي مع بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا بقطع الحوار مع روسيا لكن ذلك لم
يفضي الى شيء فظهر تغير في العقيده
العسكريه الفرنسيه ذلك تمثل بان باريس
اصبحت اكثر وضوحا في تموضعها الاقرب الى
كييف بعدما فرنسي قد دعا الى عدم اذلال
روسيا او حتى التفاوض على السلام مع موسكو
لكن ذلك اثار ايضا انتقادات كثيره بالقول
ان الاسلحه التي ترسلها فرنسا الى
اوكرانيا ليست كافيه
فرنسا ترسل الى اوكرانيا الاسلحه التي
تحتاجها اوكرانيا ليست بحاجه لان ترسل
اليها كل الدول طائرات حربيه او مدرعات
عسكريه ودبابات خفيفه او ثقيله كل بلد
عليه تقديمه منظومات الاسلحه المفيده
لاوكرانيا
لكن مع ذلك كان تكييف تامل باستلام دبابات
لوكلير الفرنسيه لكن هذه المساله تبدو
بعيده المنال فوفق مصادر عسكريه فرنسيه
ارسال هذه الدبابات لن يقدم اي قيمه
اضافيه على الارض بل سيعقد التنظيم
العسكري للجيش الاوكراني
فرنسا لن ترسل دبابات لوكلاغ لان هناك
اعداد هائله من الدبابات نحو ثلاثمائه
وخمسين دبابه ستتسلمها اوكرانيا من
الاوروبيين وخصوصا من المانيا وبولندا
لذلك فرنسا ستواصل ارسال انظمه مضاده
للدبابات وسترسل انظمه الدفاع الجوي
المتوسطه المدى محموله من طراز ممبا مع
ايطاليا
هذه الاسلحه التي تقدمها فرنسا وعلى الرغم
من انتقادات حول الكميات الا انها دفعت
باريس الى تسريع وزياده عمليات الانتاج
وهذا الامر اصبح موضع مشاورات منتظمه بين
رؤساء هيئه الاركان في الجيش الفرنسي من
اجل الاستعداد لاي سيناريو قد تفرضه روسيا
في الميدان فجده العربيه باريس